are the asteroids there may be a million
perhaps two million of these
cold dark rocks but these small worlds
are
anything but dull in fact some of them
are time capsules from the very
beginning of the solar system
unaltered for billions of years and in
fact the clues to how everything around
us began
from the formation of the planets to the
beginning of life itself
may be locked up in these asteroids and
tonight a spacecraft from earth
is going to touch one bring back a
sample and prepare the long journey back
to earth where we can analyze it
welcome everyone i'm michelle from
nasa's goddard space flight center
and thank you for joining us i'm
speaking to you live from the mission
support area at the lockheed martin
space
lockheed martin space in littleton
colorado as you can see i'm struggling
with my mask here a little bit
we're here to follow the sample
collection for nasa's osiris-rex mission
this is an operation referred to
appropriately as tag
now remember that this is a historic
event today's endeavor will be the first
time the space agency has
ever touched the surface of an asteroid
collecting a sample of this pristine
ancient material a scientific treasure
far more precious than gold
joining me throughout the show will be
the principal investigator of the
osiris-rex mission dante loretta welcome
dante
thank you michelle it's really great to
be here today i'm a professor at the
university of arizona
and i have the honor and the privilege
of leading this amazing mission for nasa
and really for the world that's pretty
amazing so now the main event is
happening in about an
hour and uh we actually uh um this is
called tag can you explain to us a bit
why it's called tag
yeah we today we're tagging an asteroid
and tag is an acronym that describes our
sample
collection strategy we're going to send
the spacecraft down for a short duration
contact with the asteroid surface
anywhere between five
and maybe as long as 15 seconds so we
call it a touch
and go or tag an asteroid it actually is
almost sort of like a quick touch of tag
it's a very great good way of putting it
exactly yeah absolutely so there's lots
of asteroids out there we talked about
the fact that there are a couple million
so why have we selected this particular
one to sample yeah the target of our
mission is called asteroid bennu
and when we were designing the mission
we had to consider both engineering
constraints
and of course our science objectives and
when we looked at the capabilities of
our spacecraft
we knew we needed to go what was to what
was called a near-earth asteroid
so we're basically looking at its
orbital properties and its location
within the solar system
needed an object whose orbit was pretty
similar to the earth
so that we could launch off of our
planet rendezvous and spend some time at
the asteroid
and then leave and bring this precious
scientific cargo back to earth
absolutely and then from the science
perspective we're really answering some
fundamental questions
why are we here why is earth a habitable
planet
how did the origin of life occur so we
wanted an asteroid
that we thought was rich in water that
may have brought the
oceans to our planet and also rich in
carbon we're looking for the organic
seeds of life
that may have led to evolution as we
know it today and this is really
an amazing point our connection to these
asteroids so what you're saying is that
some of the
organic compounds in my body some of the
water in my body right now
may originally have come from asteroids
almost certainly the earth was accreted
from these asteroids
bennu is a remnant that survived that
process
but it's the geologic history of our
solar system that's locked inside this
body
absolutely now there are many other
asteroids like benue in the solar system
and of course there are some that are
even larger over the last decades
we believe we have found nearly all of
the potentially dangerous ones
orex natural feature tracking system has
resumed processing
position uncertainty is 1.6 meters
so getting back to my point we know
there are others out there that we have
not yet detected
you know in in fact just this past
august a truck-sized asteroid missed the
earth by less than 2 000 miles
and nobody even knew it was headed our
way until it already passed us by
so for our survival it's essential that
we understand what's out there
in our environment in space and this is
one of the main objectives of the
osiris-rex mission
we'd like to go out and meet bennu
before something like bennu comes and
meets all of us
so dante what can you tell us about this
idea of planetary defense
so as a result of being having this
optimal orbit for sample return
it also is what we call a potentially
hazardous asteroid
because its orbit literally does cross
the orbit of the earth
and there's a probability about 150
years in the future that bennu may in
fact
impact our planet creating a natural
disaster
so osiris-rex is really trying to study
bennu's orbit very precisely
we know that sunlight actually
influences the trajectory of these small
asteroids
and we're studying that phenomena how it
interacts with the asteroid surface
and ultimately how it's going to allow
us to assess the impact risk
that bennu poses to the earth absolutely
so the idea of planetary defense
isn't just an intellectual exercise it's
something that nasa takes very seriously
a little later in the broadcast we're
going to talk with some people but more
about protecting the planet from
surprise visitors from space
so back to bennu we have a lot of
exciting stuff to share with you about
this tag operation from how it works to
why this overall mission matters so much
and you can be part of this too by
joining us on our social media platforms
i'd like to introduce james trayley at
our social media desk james
yeah thanks michelle my name is james
trayley and i'm a producer at nasa
guider space flight center
and today i'm joining you on social
media to share the excitement of the
osiris-rex mission
and this incredible sample collection
event at asteroid venom
to join us today you can use the hashtag
to bennu and back
on instagram facebook and twitter to
join the conversation and share the
excitement with all of us here
you can also follow the missions twitter
account at osiris-rex
for live updates as we make our tag
attempt we actually have a poll going on
at this twitter right now
but we're asking you how much sample do
you think osiris-rex will pick up at
venue today
i'll check back in with you in a little
bit for the results but for now
back to you michelle thanks james okay
so right behind me is the msa the
mission support area for osiris-rex
and today it is filled with very excited
people the scientists
engineers and technical specialists
who've worked on this mission in some
cases for more than a decade
so back there is gary napier from
lockheed martin he's right in the middle
of it all
so uh gary what's the feeling in the
room
michelle like you said i am just right
behind you about 20 feet we're here in
the larger lockheed martin mission
support area
where we're operating six of nasa
spacecraft around the solar system
four of them at mars one of them at
jupiter and this one right here
osiris-rex we're gonna take you into the
operations center here at osiris-rex
this is where the flight team is right
now
the um controllers are already on board
we've heard some good call outs right
now
in a little while we're going to come in
here and talk to some of them and see
how things are going
it's looking really good right now back
to you michelle
thanks gary so i think right now we have
to acknowledge something that this is a
bit of an unusual broadcast we're
dealing with some pretty big challenges
tonight
because we're doing this all in the
midst of a pandemic so you'll notice
that i'm wearing a mask i've certainly
never hosted an event wearing a mask
before
forgive me if i struggle with it a
little bit tonight make sure that it's
in the right position
and when we interview people you'll
notice that we'll be standing farther
away than normal
and also i'm going to stay right here
normally i might be back in the mission
support area but i'm not allowed to go
back there i'm isolated from them
so it's amazing that with the incredible
operation going on at bennu tonight
and the people all around me who have
been working on this for years to make
this a success
we still have to deal with the
challenges of covid19 and so you know
tonight our attention is going to be on
this wonderful event
actually sampling an asteroid and you
know that's incredibly adventurous it's
very happy
but we're going to remember to actually
take care of each other we can't forget
that
so please bear with us today as we are
working with our masks and trying to do
this the best way we can okay
so uh dante uh give us a chance now give
us sort of an idea about how the
engineers back there are actually flying
osiris-rex
so it's important to understand that the
spacecraft is actually
literally on the other side of the solar
system over 200 million miles away from
the earth
so any signal that we were to transmit
here would take over 18 and a half
minutes to reach the spacecraft
so when we get these signals back we're
actually seeing things that happened in
the past at the asteroid
as a result we have to have a very smart
spacecraft it has to make its own
guidance calculations and make its own
decisions
and in fact instead of getting high data
back we're only getting a very low data
rate
what we call breadcrumbs just key pieces
of information from the spacecraft
that tell us when key events have taken
place in the tag sequence
overx has processed its next image
position uncertainty
is 0.9 meters
so that's an example of the kind of
information that we're getting back from
the spacecraft it's got its onboard
natural feature tracking system which
we're going to hear a lot more about
today
absolutely yeah all right so i guess
after that
we are dealing with um you know actually
the tag event itself but i understand
that we're not going to be able to see
images tonight in real time do we have
to wait a while
why is that uh the images take a lot of
data to bring back to the space
bring back from the spacecraft to the
earth and since we're on that low data
rate what we're using today
is this real-time simulation that we've
put together so what we're seeing here
and we'll be
referring to this throughout the
broadcast tonight uh this isn't
any kind of real information from outer
space this is
uh what we expect the spacecraft to be
doing so it'll
let us know when key events are
programmed to take place on the
spacecraft and to be received back on
earth
there may be some lags in communication
but this is going to really help us
visualize what's actually happening at
asteroid bennu
so when will we expect those those first
images uh so
everything's going to play out at this
very low data rate through most of the
broadcast today and then the spacecraft
has to back away from the asteroid
surface it has to cool off it has to get
back on its solar arrays
and then it's going to turn that high
gain antenna to the earth this evening
and we expect images to be coming in
overnight and we hope to have some great
information for everybody by tomorrow
i'm really looking forward to those
images people around the world are
so at this point the spacecraft has left
its home orbit
and it's on its way to the sample site
and every minute now we're drawing near
to that moment
when osiris-rex touches the surface of
bennu so while we're waiting let's check
in with james at our social media desk
yeah thanks michelle so a few days ago
we actually hosted a reddit ama with a
few of our scientists
and got a lot of fantastic questions we
wanted to recap a couple of them for you
right now so our first question asks how
is it possible to map such a tiny
speckle in the sky
do you have any detailed images that you
can share do you really see the landing
site or is it all based on measurements
of some weird properties and
calculations
so yes our first observation of bennu
actually came from right here on earth
from the arecibo observatory in puerto
rico
this huge radio telescope gave us a
basic understanding of the rough shape
of bennu
this kind of strange top-like shape that
you see right here
as osiris-rex was actually out in space
and began making its approach
closer and closer to the asteroid it
used its suite of onboard camera
instruments to actually
image the surface in increasing detail
then it grew in detail from just a few
tiny pixels on our screen
to this super high resolution world that
you see right here
littered with giant rugged boulders
another question from reddit is asking
us
see here as it loads in yes so would it
have been feasible to have a robotic arm
pick up a rock
would a single rock have been better
than 100 tiny grains of sand or ice
so the team had originally designed
osiris-rex to sample on a nice flat
sandy-like surface but as you just saw
bennu is not at all like that
it's super rugged and filled with giant
boulders so the team had to work with
what we had designed for which was that
flat sandy surface
if we were to try to sample on a rock
that actually presents a number of
challenges of its own
for example if we were to pick up a rock
it might actually just crumble away and
we wouldn't actually get a sample out of
it
also some of these rocks might actually
be a bit too stuck to the surface
and if we were to try to pry those loose
they might not actually budge and we
won't actually even get a sample
so these are all things that the team
has to consider when designing something
that's going to be operating
millions upon millions of miles away
from us here on earth so for now
back to you michelle thanks james we'll
be back to you more for later
okay now i have been a star wars fan
nearly all my life and uh in one movie
darth vader said rather famously that
asteroids do not concern me
but that is certainly not true for us
this evening we are all about asteroids
here at the mission support area in
littleton colorado
and we are bringing you live coverage of
our attempt to collect a sample from the
asteroid bennu
now osiris-rex is a one-of-a-kind
spacecraft with an extraordinary team of
engineers and scientists charting
unexplored places
it was launched on september 8 2016. the
vehicle has traveled over
2.2 billion miles on a complex route to
reach bennu
it's scheduled to deliver its precious
cargo back to earth in 2023
so now let's take a closer look at
osiris-rex
over 200 million miles away from earth
nasa's osiris-rex spacecraft
is preparing for an ambitious sample
collection attempt at asteroid bennu
before it makes its approach to the
rocky surface let's take a look back at
some of the incredible firsts for this
mission which almost seemed like
something out of a hollywood movie
this is the first asteroid sample return
mission for nasa
and it could be the largest return from
space since the apollo astronauts
brought moon samples back to earth
while getting set to grab a sample
osiris-rex has set not one
but two guinness world records its first
for the smallest ever
body orbited and its second for the
closest weapon of the spacecraft
this tight orbit has brought the
spacecraft so close to bennett that
osiris-rex's on-board cameras
and laser altimeter have been able to
image and characterize the asteroid
surface and shape
better than earth our own moon or any
other celestial body
osiris-rex has image bennu down to 5
centimeter per pixel resolution
providing us with an unprecedented view
into this rocky
and boulder-filled world
with 28 onboard thrusters osiris-rex is
one of the most maneuverable spacecrafts
this allows it to carefully and
precisely descend to a spot on bennu
that is no larger than a few parking
spaces there's certainly been some
unexpected twists along the way
however osiris-rex has capitalized on
these moments
right after arriving at the asteroid
osiris-rex imaged rocky ejecta that has
been bursting off bennett
this is the first time we have been able
to observe the entire life cycle
of a natural satellite ejecting off an
object entering into orbit
and returning back to the surface
because of bennu's extremely rocky
surface
the team needed to adapt the
spacecraft's navigation method
to an optical approach known as natural
feature tracking or nft
this is the first time this approach has
been used in space and it will allow
osiris-rex to steer itself down
to collect a sample from bennett
and now osiris-rex is looking to set
another first for nasa
successfully collect a sample of an
asteroid and deliver it to earth
by 2023
welcome back if you're just joining us
i'm michelle thaller from nasa's goddard
space flight center and with me is dante
loretta from the university of arizona
and you are here with us on a historic
evening it will be nasa's first sample
return from an asteroid the attempt to
actually sample the asteroid bennu
the spacecraft osiris-rex is descending
toward bennu right now
to take a sample and return it back to
earth so dante let's talk more about
this real-time simulation that we're
looking at
yeah it's been an exciting day already
michelle we're well over three hours
into the tag sequence which is the
pre-programmed
uh set of commands that are already on
the spacecraft uh earlier we departed
our orbit around the asteroid so we're
flying over the sunlit side of the
asteroid
taking images for the onboard guidance
system called natural feature tracking
a couple other key events that have
taken place already is the spacecraft
has deployed its robotic
tag sam sampling arm so the arm is ready
in position to collect that sample
and we've turned on and started
collecting science data from one of our
science instruments the otis
thermal emission spectrometer the
spacecraft has already moved into its
second
natural feature tracking attitude and is
getting on board positional updates as
we speak
and i can tell you everything is going
exactly according to plan right now it
looks really good
oh it's an exciting day so osiris-rex
has traveled more than two and a half
years as it navigated its way to this
delicate orbit around bennu and once
there it began mapping the surface one
of the many tasks it in the engineering
team had been conducting since it
arrived
and there have been some challenges and
surprises too correct
absolutely i can tell you already the
science return from osiris-rex has been
phenomenal and rewritten a lot of things
about what we know about asteroids
i'm going to talk really about three of
some of the most interesting
results for me first off we learned
literally about one week after getting
into orbit that bennu is what we call an
active asteroid it is ejecting particles
from its surface
these particles are coming off at
relatively low velocities for the most
they're actually going into orbit
spiraling around the asteroid
providing some excellent science
allowing us to map out the gravity field
of this small body at an unprecedented
detail way beyond what we expected to do
uh the other thing that we saw right
away as we were approaching is that
there was some a generally
dark black surface as expected but there
are these really bright boulders that
were shining like beacons to us
and as we trained our science
instruments on there and characterized
their mineralogy
we were actually able to link them to
another asteroid called vesta
one of the largest asteroids in the
solar system and actually the target of
nasa's dawn spacecraft which did a
phenomenal job characterizing this
target
and this just shows that these asteroids
are exchanging pieces
back and forth as they collide into each
other and shoot their particles off into
space
over has processed its next image
position uncertainty
is 0.6 meters wow
and i would say uh back to the science
the final result that
that really is important from this
mission is we did expect this asteroid
to look
sandy and beach like and that was based
on the thermal properties as determined
from telescopic observations from earth
and we got there and we used the otis
and our ovir spectrometer to map
and produce a thermal inertia
characterization of the entire surface
and everything turned itself upside down
based on our models
the areas that we thought would be beach
like based on thermal properties
turned out to be the largest boulders on
the asteroid surface and the more
fine-grained regions turned turned out
to have what we call this higher thermal
inertia
completely opposite of everything we
expected propagating a lot of great
science
as a result and so when you mention that
there are these bright rocks from vesta
does that
that means that bennu was once in the
asteroid belt between mars and jupiter
that's right bennu is currently a
near-earth asteroid but it has it's a
recent wanderer into the inner solar
system
we actually think it's uh fragments of a
much larger asteroid that was
catastrophically disrupted
maybe a billion years ago wow that is so
cool thank you so much
okay now as challenging as it is
actually getting to bennu capturing a
sample of the asteroid is something else
entirely
and the team needed to develop this
remarkable system the osiris-rex mission
has been in development for almost 20
years with the engineers and scientists
developing new technologies and
strategies
to accomplish something that's honestly
never been done before and this is
particularly challenging because bennu
has such a weak gravity field
so when you think about going into orbit
around something how do you orbit
something where the gravity can't
grab you and actually push you into
orbit it's all about flying the
spacecraft
it's also very difficult to take a
sample in a very low gravity environment
so thankfully we have the mastermind
behind the device that's going to take
the sample tonight lockheed martin's
beau beerhouse welcome beau
thank you michelle it's great to be here
okay so let's talk a bit about why
working in this low gravity environment
makes it tough to get a sample because
you might think sort of at first you
could just take like a robotic claw
a robotic arm and scoop something up but
that's not going to work in these
conditions
that's exactly right the microgravity of
bennu provides a challenge of
sampling that we don't normally face on
earth you can imagine trying to use a
shovel or a scoop on earth
and the ground pushes against you but
the gravity keeps you on the ground
on bennu the surface gravity is
thousands of times lower than on earth
so if you pushed a shovel or a scoop
into the ground you'd push yourself
right off the surface
so we had to come up with a technique
that worked within this very low gravity
we also had the challenge of uncertainty
of the mechanical properties of the
surface
and both of those things made landing a
challenge we wouldn't know how to
grapple particularly well
in this material so we had to come up
with a technique that worked in the
microgravity environment
and that could work in this tag
architecture this touch and go
architecture of just a few seconds long
now i understand you have brought some
models with you both of the spacecraft
and of the instrument that will be
taking samples so
show us what you've got here that's
exactly right so this is a scale model
of the spacecraft
the arm is extended in the sampling
position
part way down the arm you can see three
gas bottles we'll use one of them today
this has high pressure nitrogen gas
which passes down the arm
into the tag sam head itself and here i
have actually
a full scale tag sam it's actually a
device that we used for collection
testing on earth
the gas comes down i don't have the
tubing here to show you but the gas
comes down to the center of the tag exam
is split into two
and passes underneath the head there is
now a high pressure bubble of gas
underneath the head that is mobilizing
material much like wind blows
dirt on a dusty day on the earth and
we're surrounded by the vacuum of space
so the gas is there's a high pressure
gas underneath tag sam and it will
escape
into the low pressure environment of the
vacuum of space surrounding it
and it does so through this screen
around the entire perimeter of the tag
sam head itself
but while the gas can escape the screen
traps the material safely inside
it's one of these sort of brilliant
things about engineering for space is to
have things that are
really really rigorously built and they
can't break easily and so
there aren't even any moving parts here
and you're using the vacuum of space
itself
to provide the pressure to collect the
sample that's exactly right when we were
first designing this device
many years ago we were thinking we
wanted to keep it as simple and as
robust and as full proof as possible
we didn't want any mechanisms we didn't
want any electrical devices
the entire collection is driven by the
dynamics of the gas itself
so once the gas is released from the
bottle and travels down the arm
the gas does all the work that's so cool
so what size particles are we talking
about collecting here
well tag sam is designed to collect two
centimeter particles
and i have some examples here to show
you so this is a two centimeter sphere
it's about the same diameter as a nickel
but of course most geologic materials
aren't actually perfect spheres most
geologic materials are irregularly
shaped
rex has processed its next image
position uncertainty
is 0.5 meters that is fantastic
excellent so we're going where we need
to go to get this material
so most geologic material is irregularly
shaped so this
rock is actually about four centimeters
long in its longest dimension but we
were still able to collect this in a
test on earth
and that's because even though it's four
centimeters in this dimension
you can see that much less than two
centimeters in that dimension or even
two centimeters in the other dimension
so while we're limited in in one
direction for two centimeters
as long as the other two directions are
less we can actually collect
uh much larger particles into the tags
itself
well excellent so i understand we have
some animations queued up to give us a
sense of what's going to happen on the
asteroid tonight sure thing
so what you're seeing is the spacecraft
descending at a leisurely 10 centimeters
per second to the surface
15 times walking speed it contacts
the spacecraft senses contact and fires
the gas
the gas mobilizes material underneath
the tag sam head
that gas escapes into the vacuum of
space through the perimeter and
materials collected into the taxam head
the spacecraft fires its thrusters and
backs safely away from the surface of
the asteroid
well thank you for the tutorial though i
mean clearly the science community is
going to be very excited to study
whatever tag sam collects so
thank you so much thank you it's
wonderful to be here
okay well speaking of all the important
tag the thing that's happening in less
than an hour
uh right now before we get any later it
would be a good time for us to get a
tour of the nerve center here at
lockheed martin space in littleton
colorado
right behind me is the mission support
area or msa
and osiris-rex team members are keeping
an eye on the spacecraft right now
so let's send it over to gary what's
going on gary so as i showed you earlier
we're just around the corner from you
this is the
heart of the tag operations and we
thought this would actually be a really
good time to kind of check in with the
team
see how things are going and the best
person to do that
is joining me and this is sandy friend
she's the osiris-rex operations manager
here at lockheed martin so
sandy thanks for joining us how's the
team doing
oh the team is great we've been here on
consoles since six o'clock this morning
sending the final commands getting ready
for tag
really cool i know there's like 40
people on your overall flight team but
it seems like there's about 20 of them
here
right now maybe kind of give us a little
idea of who some of these folks are and
what they're doing
yeah absolutely so this is the amazing
rx team you can see
all of our subsystems here on console
monitoring their telemetry
like you mentioned we can't have
everybody in here we do have many team
members supporting from other conference
rooms in the building and some even from
home
so let's talk about a couple of the
positions we have in the room in the
back corner over there is dale howe
dale is our tag phase lead you've been
hearing his voice calling out events as
they complete on board the spacecraft
here in the center area we have curtis
miller curtis is our nft lead
he is watching natural feature tracking
and that is how we are navigating to the
surface of benny today
so he is watching how nft is performing
how many features we're matching
and how that system is working so i know
natural feature tracking like you're
saying is kind of keeping an eye on
telling us where we're going and i know
we're going to get into that a little
bit later in the show
but also it's important to stay in
communications with the spacecraft so
what what about coms yeah absolutely so
right behind me here sierra gonzalez
she's a real-time operator or ace
she is working with our deep space
network partners currently we're on a
station in goldstone and in canberra
making sure we maintain our calm link
and our calm link is only 40 bits per
second so we're just bringing down that
key information but sierra's here to
make sure
we keep that link going and our station
operator is informed
and right next to her is estelle church
and estelle is our systems coordinator
for this event
she's built all the command products
that are executing she's keeping an eye
on how everything is progressing on
board the spacecraft talking to all of
our subsystems here in the room
and making sure things are going just as
planned very good i know you yourself
have actually been on this um
project for quite a while we've been
no actually i'm excited um i feel like
we've done everything we can to make
this successful and
i've been on this mission for seven
years so i've watched it go from a
spacecraft on paper to being built in
our high bay
to launch and everything here and yeah
i'm excited my kids were excited this
morning and we are ready
right on that's so fantastic so we're
going to let you guys get back to it i
know we don't want to interrupt too much
sandy thank you so much for joining us
and i know that uh
folks around the world are paying
attention to this right now we're seeing
a ton of social media coming in so
let's go over to james on the social
media desk and see what some of those
conversations are about
yeah thanks gary it's awesome to see the
team over there in the msa you can
really feel the energy in the room
especially after every call out from
dale and
to the tag attitude the third and final
natural feature tracking attitude
all right so we're inching ever so
closer down to the surface of bennu
but today we also want to hear from you
so you can check in
on live updates at our twitter account
at osiris-rex we're using that hashtag
to benue back across social media to get
in on the conversation
in the meantime a question i had when i
first started covering the mission is
how do you even begin to prepare for a
mission of this scale i mean when i
first heard about osiris-rex it really
seemed like something out of a
big-budget movie
but this is a reality we're actually
going to be trying to sample on an
asteroid
to put things into perspective for you
bennu is about the size
of the empire state building that's
really small for an object and makes it
exceptionally challenging for us to
orbit something with such a weak gravity
field
and that sample site we're going for
today nightingale it's just
a few meters in width which is about the
size of a few parking spaces
so just take a step back for a second
and put yourself in the shoes of some of
those engineers on this mission
and imagine trying to park a spacecraft
on an asteroid
200 million miles away and a space no
larger than a few parking spots
as if parallel parking on an asteroid
isn't hard enough
imagine also trying to dodge hazards
like rocky boulders and
all kinds of things as you're making
your descent down to collect a sample
and on top of that the team has actually
programmed the spacecraft to steer
itself down to the surface
it's it's truly incredible this mission
and all the foresight that went into it
it really blows my mind
we actually have a couple questions
coming in from twitter and a lot of
people are actually asking about our
fuel usage for the mission
this one question is asking how does the
craft have enough fuel to return back to
earth
from the asteroid so we're looking to
bring that symbol back in 2023
and osiris-rex is thrusters are actually
powered by hydrazine which is stored in
a container on the spacecraft
we're tapping into a little bit of that
fuel today on the order of maybe tens of
grams not a lot
because as you remember bennu has this
microgravity environment and it just
requires a little bit of thrust to kick
us in the right direction to collect a
sample
that return trip back to earth that's a
bit of a different story we're going to
be using a lot more fuel for that
but don't worry the team has thought way
ahead and has packed more than enough
fuel to get us back here safely in 2023
but there's a lot more to come and i'll
check back in with you in just a minute
thank you michelle thank you james okay
so let's take a quick look at the
simulation to see where we are
as you notice with the simulation the
spacecraft has its arm extended now
and is on a slow path toward the surface
so as we get closer to the moment of
contact the drama starts to happen in
slow motion
and this is to maximize precision and
minimize unintentional surprises
so speaking of surprises there is a one
big aspect of the osiris-rex mission
that's all about preparing for the
unexpected
and joining us to discuss this is nasa
planetary science division director
lori glaze now laura you have kind of a
dramatic specialty
and a responsibility that comes with
your position at nasa you actually worry
about things like planetary protection
yes planetary protection planetary
defenses
defenses defending our planet from
potential impacts and
bennu is in a special class and i think
dante spoke about this little earlier
that
bennu is actually a near-earth object or
a neo
um and a neo or near-earth object um is
an asteroid or a comet that orbits the
sun much like our planets do
uh but they're slightly unusual reeks
overx has reached the third and final
natural feature tracking attitude
the spacecraft will hold this fixed
attitude until tagged
excellent great news so back to neos yes
so neos are somewhat unusual in that
their orbits bring them
within the vicinity of earth's orbit um
the technical definition of a
neo is something that comes within about
30 million miles of earth's orbit
um and asteroids actually come close to
the earth all the time
one or two per week actually pass in
between the earth and the moon
but most of those are really small and
not dangerous but asteroids of a much
bigger size
that could actually do damage to the
earth's surface if they were to impact
um they can pass by earth closer than
the moon about once per month
and that's why it's really important for
us to find them
as early as possible so we can track
their orbits
study their characteristics and if
necessary we can mitigate
a potential future impact threat and
that's where
a mission that we're building now called
the double asteroid redirection test
that's where dart comes in and dart is
going to launch in next summer
2021 and it's going to test something we
call
the kinetic impactor technique that
could be used one day to help us
mitigate a future potential impact
threat
by bumping an asteroid ever slow
slightly
on a that's on a completion course with
our planet into a slightly different
orbit so it misses earth
just a little bit is all you need just a
tiny bit
so i mean that is really exciting now i
also understand that not all of the
asteroids in the solar system are the
same
there are different sorts and nasa has
some upcoming missions to study
these different kinds of asteroids so
tell us a bit more about that please
absolutely yeah we know that the
majority of our asteroids are found
in the main asteroid belt between mars
and jupiter
and in fact we have a mission that's
going to launch in 2022
it's called psyche uh it's going to
visit one of the the biggest
asteroids in the asteroid belt that's
actually called 16 psyche
and this mission um is going to arrive
in early 2026 and help us better
understand
um if this asteroid is potentially
actually the core
of a planet-sized object we also have
other types of asteroids called trojans
that are clustered in two groups that
lead and trail
in jupiter's orbit due to a balancing
act of the pull of both jupiter's and
the sun's
gravity on them that has a mission to
those trojan asteroids called lucy
it's going to launch next year next fall
about a year from now
and it's going to go visit several of
these trojan asteroids
we have a new mission called janus and
we selected this mission through
our simplex small mission program line
this mission is going to send actually
two small spacecraft
very small spacecraft to two binary
asteroid systems
and help us understand what it is that
makes these binary asteroid systems
different from one another
and so studying this full breadth of
these diverse small worlds will continue
to help
us fill up the knowledge gaps of how our
solar system actually formed and evolved
over time
so it seems without these missions
coming up we're sort of in a golden age
of asteroid exploration
but then there's this other aspect of
the osiris-rex mission which is the
sample return
and it turns out that we're also
beginning this golden age of sample
return to it and not just
asteroids you're absolutely right and
we're really excited about all these
samples because they're so precious
precious and there's so much science we
can do with them in addition to
osiris-rex
we're also partnering with the japanese
space agency on their mission called
hayabusa 2
which is actually already on its way
back bringing a sample from
ryugu they're going to be coming back to
earth in december
we're also partnering with japanese
space agency on another mission of
theirs
that's going to return a sample from
phobos which is one of the two moons
of mars and then finally at the end of
this decade
we're going to send a mission to mars to
retrieve the samples
that are collected by the perseverance
rover which is really
truly our first astrobiology mission
from nasa
and it's focused on looking for finding
potential life ancient life
on mars so sample of return is really
important
because it allows us to study these
pristine samples back here on earth
we can then take advantage of our
room-sized laboratories
all of this off orex has begun moving
the solar arrays to the y-wing
configuration
to avoid possible contact with the
surface during tag
great news moving right along so when we
bring the samples back this allows us to
use
all of the laboratory capabilities that
we have here on earth we can use the
full suite
of the scientific instruments that we
have at our disposal to help us better
understand the sample their compositions
and the history of the body from which
they came
and also having the samples back here on
earth allows us to preserve them
for future generations to come and
allows their future explorers to analyze
the samples using techniques um
instruments that haven't been invented
and to ask questions that we don't even
know to ask yet
that is just so cool i mean your life is
all about how we navigate unknowns this
is something that's happening in real
time around us tonight
so it's reassuring to know that there's
an organized plan that you're in charge
of to help take some of the
uncertainties out of at least one
dramatic category
so lori glease thank you for joining us
this evening so good to see you thank
you so much for having me i just want to
add that it's been fantastic to watch
the osiris-rex mission um so far and i'm
really really excited
for what's ahead tonight and i want to
say congratulations to the entire team
thank you so much thank you now
asteroids are not easily navigated
they're hard to see they have low
gravity fields they're dark and rocky
and traveling around the solar system
where everything is moving
rarely means traveling in a straight
line let's take a look at some of the
big challenges the team has faced to get
to this point
as we started to approach bennu from a
distance and it started to fill up the
camera field of view it looked exactly
like we thought it would with a few
boulders sticking out but as we got
closer
we expected to see a very sandy surface
with maybe
a few boulders here and there and what
we saw is
very little sand and we saw these
mountains we saw boulders we saw
rocks and we saw very few areas that had
this sandy surface that we were
expecting and what we have designed to
we have never done this before we're
actually going to collect a sample
and bring it back down to earth for
further examination by scientists
in order to achieve that objective the
osiris-rex spacecraft has been
navigating around bennu for about the
last two years
studying it in great detail and also
overcoming a number of challenges
that venue has presented we were looking
for locations on venue that were 50
meters in diameter
relatively flat and covered with
fine-grained material and by fine-grain
material i mean stuff that's the size of
a dime or smaller
we realized that there were no sites on
venue that even came close to meeting
this criteria everywhere we looked was
too small
and covered with boulders so we actually
had to fly a number of additional close
passes over the asteroid
and rethink our entire plan for grabbing
the sample
after the additional observations of
bennu we had to down select to four
sites
and then go back and survey those sites
even further to select the final primary
sample site
my first impression of nightingale is
that's the last place i wanted to go
but as we started looking at other sites
we saw that one this is probably one of
the most sampleable sites
and two we were over performing in our
navigation capability and our ability to
contact
natural feature tracking works a lot
like the human mind in that we pick up
landmarks along the way
as we descend we look at features on the
ground we program the computer to
recognize certain features it takes a
picture says
this feature is not where i expected it
to be it's a little bit off to the side
updates its position based on where it's
pointed and where that feature shows up
in the camera position
the tag event is our touch and go event
which is where we'll actually be
retrieving the sample from asteroid
bennu
we start with a series of maneuvers one
of them being the checkpoint burn which
is where we'll actually check our
position velocity in relation
to the sample sites and then the match
point burn about 10 minutes later
we'll zero out our horizontal velocity
relative to the surface
and then about 10 minutes after that we
make contact with the tag sam
fire the gas bottle and then back away
and we hope to get
at least 60 grams of sample and then
we'll be able to store
that and bring it back down to earth but
there are several things that could go
wrong and we also have to be prepared
that we won't be successful on our first
try
at nightingale we don't only get one
shot at
tag we actually have three nitrogen
bottles on board the spacecraft so we
can potentially do
three tag attempts if needed we go
through several
what-if scenarios and this is how we
actually prepare for a lot of our
contingencies
so we've had to look all around the
surface and identify the
rocks and boulders that if the
spacecraft were to tip over up to 25
degrees
it could come into contact and be
damaged we had to develop a hazard map
which we program into the computer and
says
if you're getting too close to those
hazards we'll do a wave off
we'll back away from the asteroid we'll
come back and do this another
day everything might work perfectly we
come down we touch the surface just
where we want to
we fire the gas bottle but the area we
contact
is covered in large rocks those rocks
would prevent any fine grain material
from being stirred up
and captured in the tag sam head another
similar scenario
is if the tag sam were to touch on the
edge of a boulder and become tipped up
in that case when the gas bottle fires
much of that gas escapes out the side
not churning up the material that we
want to capture the day of tag is going
to be really exciting but the excitement
for our team doesn't end there
we have to verify that we have a proper
sample
first we're going to image the tag sam
head by sticking in front of one of the
cameras then we're going to do a
maneuver called the sample mass
measurement in which we stick out the
arm and we spin the spacecraft
in order for us to decide if we've
collected enough mass to be able to stow
the sample
and return home or if we have to try
again this is the culmination
of a lot of work it's probably one of
the most exciting missions that i've
worked on it is really exciting to know
that we're finally going to be able to
touch the surface of the asteroid and
collect the sample to return back to
earth
so step back for a moment and realize
that tonight's events are exceedingly
rare and historic
humanity has only landed on a few
different bodies in the solar system and
actually retrieving a sample is even
more rare
so luckily with me tonight are some of
the people that know better than anybody
all the challenges that it took to get
here so let me introduce mike moreau
mike is the osiris-rex deputy project
manager at the goddard space flight
center and coralie adam
is tag navigation manager at kinetics
aerospace
so welcome mike and coralie how you guys
doing so excited
we're less than half hour from tag now
yeah where you could feel the energy all
building so
i should mention at this point that it's
possible you've been hearing this before
cheers from the msa
so can you give us a sense what's going
on right now yeah so every few minutes a
navigation camera image is taken by the
spacecraft of the surface below
and it's sent to the natural feature
tracking system and that system uh
identifies features in the image and
sends a signal back to earth
that it was successful
0.5 meters and the team celebrates
it tells us we're on track to our next
target and on track attack
right absolutely so now clearly there's
a lot to talk about in terms of the
mission but once again you had to do all
of this in the midst of this covet 19
pandemic so were there any mission
expectations that changed
how did you deal with that yeah for sure
i mean as the whole world was coming to
grips with the pandemic in the march
time frame
this team was in the midst of preparing
for our first tag rehearsal
the checkpoint rehearsal that would take
the spacecraft only 65 meters above the
surface
so we had to rethink the entire way in
which we were going to do that rehearsal
with only a skeleton crew here in the
building and with many of our team
members remote as sandy mentioned before
today we have people
literally all over the building
monitoring also at goddard space flight
center and at the university of arizona
watching this event today but thankfully
we got through checkpoint rehearsal in
april and match play rehearsal in august
and all the special considerations
they're still going on around us today
right
yeah i mean you could see people spaced
out in the msa when you're over there
and um you know we we had more time to
prepare for tag
in order to accommodate that and get
everyone into the building here today so
i'm just incredibly proud of our team
uh for you know their efforts to keep
the project on track for tag in spite of
all of these challenges
absolutely so i know nasa is a famous
for having to deal with unexpected
situations and this covet 19 thing is
kind of a different flavor of unexpected
situations we're gonna deal about that
okay
so now let's talk more about the
challenges of tag that we introduced in
the video segment so corelli
right so you saw you've seen that
nightingale site is an extremely
challenging spot to navigate into
there's boulders all around it
um this is totally different than how we
originally designed the system
to target a 50 meter diameter area
nightingale is 10
times smaller than that so it required
the whole team to rethink how to safely
navigate
into the context of the surface and we
had to come up with some new ideas
yeah so the original navigation approach
used lidar or
laser based navigation uh to take us to
the nightingale crater but when we saw
what bennu looked like we realized we
had to switch to a vision-based
approach and that's the nft system that
you've been hearing about
yeah so the kinetics navigation team has
spent the last two years
learning how to navigate around venue
using optical navigation techniques
uh very similar to what nft is doing on
board the spacecraft today
so kinetics worked with scientists and
the lockheed martin and atheists
not the surface of that rex has
processed its next image
position uncertainty is 0.5 meters
so we mapped the surface of venue to
unprecedented resolution of two
centimeters per pixel which is better
than what we've done on our own
earth and moon um so it was a huge
herculean effort to get to this point
where we're comfortable
handing the maps and the keys over to
the spacecraft to get us down into this
small site today absolutely so i guess
right now it's time to say goodbye to
you guys the best of luck for today
i'm really excited and it's it's great
to be with uh
with you guys thank you michelle yeah
well so right now um i think probably
the best thing to do is to check in with
gary napier
uh so um i guess we're gonna go back and
uh and see how things are going back
there
so to gary
so things are going really good right
now michelle
we're um actually going to uh talk to uh
heather enos here of arizona
thanks for joining us heather hi gary
so what's really interesting heather is
that you actually feel that you know
long missions like this are really
important i mean you you go from design
to build but operations
is really quite a while that it's
actually really important to involve
that
next generation and kind of bring that
generation up correct
talk to us a little bit about that
absolutely gary you're right um
all the way back from when we started uh
planning this mission osiris-rex we
recognize it's a long
duration mission and although that
presents challenges for
retaining your key personnel we actually
took it as an opportunity
to use this mission to train our next
generation of students
and science engineers and scientists
a good example is we had uh one of our
science uh instruments is called rexis
it's an x-ray spectrometer built by a
team of students at mit and harvard
so real hands-on that's really
interesting i mean i understand you also
have some
folks that actually were students and
came onto the team later
yeah so being at the university of
arizona on a p.i led mission
we had hundreds of undergraduate and
graduate students working on this
mission
over the course of the last decade and
two
of our uh students that start off with
students are actually two of our
uh navigation team members that's dan
whitman and eric sarks wow they're on
iran console
they're on council right now yeah they
are at this time
nfc has computed the checkpoint and
match point burn updates
the correct for errors in the trajectory
accumulated since orbit departure
checkpoint burn in two minutes so
checkpoint turn in two minutes we're
going to
throw it back over to michelle because i
know this is an important update for her
so michelle thanks
back over to you thanks gary absolutely
so dante tell us what this important
milestone checkpoint means
this is a really important uh part of
the mission right now so we've been
hearing about natural feature tracking
and how it's processing these images
overx has processed its next image
position uncertainty
is 0.46 meters right so what it's
doing with that information is it's
calculating uh how it's going to fire
its thrusters
for this checkpoint when we left orbit
we were on a trajectory that would take
us
over the surface of the asteroid and if
nothing else happened we would safely
fly past bennu
once we fire the thrusters for the
checkpoint maneuver
we're actually going to start descending
down towards the asteroid surface so
this means we're going to be on our way
to make contact so natural feature
tracking has been doing nothing but
calculating this maneuver since we
started taking images
so this is one of the big deals this is
one of the the big milestones coming up
this is huge
yeah absolutely i know that as we look
at the simulation there's an interesting
configuration the spacecraft isn't oh i
see the thrusters firing
that's right you can see we would expect
right now on the spacecraft the
thrusters to be firing so we're going to
be paying close attention to dale howell
to let us know we've gotten telemetry
back to telling us that maneuver has
succeeded
in the meantime if you want to tell us a
bit about the configuration it's in go
ahead
yeah we heard dale call out earlier that
the spacecraft was in the y-wing
configuration there we just reconfigured
the solar rays to get them up
away from the asteroid surface basically
to protect their active areas from any
dust loading
that might be kicked up during the tag
event it's another excellent star wars
reference that's right
now always you can also see here in the
simulation the nightingale sample site
now down in the lower corner here this
is our target this is what we're trying
to get into with that spacecraft
and it looks like there's a lot of
boulders around that yeah as we've said
uh generally the surface of bennu is
rough and rugged and covered with
boulders nightingale
really does stand out as a pretty unique
interesting area on the surface
how you doing doing pretty good paying
close attention to that call out wait
for dale to tell us that checkpoint has
occurred
absolutely so what we're waiting for
right now is the call out the checkpoint
has occurred
and the uh the osiris-rex spacecraft has
begun its descent
towards the asteroid surface right any
time now
and it's probably worth mentioning forex
msa on orex ops
checkpoint burn has completed
okay we're heading down towards the
asteroid surface at this point
oh wow
oh wow okay well you know i guess um
the next thing that comes up is uh is
that would be match point maneuver so
that that's
the next big milestone for us that's
right so we've got one more firing of
thrusters with the spacecraft to get us
lined up for the sample acquisition
event we call that the match point
uh because what we're doing there
currently as we're flying over the
asteroid surface in fact it's the
asteroid surface that's rotating
underneath us
and when we fire thrusters for match
point we're doing that to match that
rotational velocity
so that the spacecraft becomes station
keeping essentially over that
nightingale sample site
absolutely all right so i think we have
a little bit time now to turn to our
social media
desk so uh james what's going on social
media yeah michelle it's
super exciting you just heard that
checkpoint burn confirmed we are now
just very very close down to the surface
of nightingale
and you guys have been really excited
over on social media too with that
hashtag to bennu and back
lots of great messages rolling in here
someone's really excited for our little
robot friend to
go rock hunting on the surface we had
someone who actually attended our launch
back in a couple years ago cape
canaveral and are now watching the
broadcast live with us today excited for
that sample collection event
we have philip who kind of puts it in
perspective for us here he says this is
amazing and extremely difficult in so
many ways
venue's orbit spin inclination the
orbital mechanics of this long mission
are just astounding
i can only imagine how many orbit
simulations have been made here on earth
it really is a crazy mission and we also
have our animal friends our pets
cheering us on here as well benny was
rough from uh this
couple of our pets here really excited
so we're now just minutes away from that
match point burn
and for that i'll take it back to you
michelle okay excellent so you know just
a few minutes ago dante you were saying
this landing site is sort of a unique
area on the asteroid
tell us about this site yeah uh we spent
an enormous amount of effort
uh selecting the area on this asteroid
surface where we wanted to get the
sample from
and we kind of divided our analysis up
into four different categories
first we were looking at the
deliverability and this was a real
challenge because as we've seen earlier
in the broadcast the original guidance
accuracy was 25 meter radius
and we're trying to get into an area
that's 10 percent of that size we have
solved that problem with our
amazing natural feature tracking
solution and as we've heard
that's worked really well and it has
updated its checkpoint and its match
point maneuvers on board based on that
information
that gets you down to the surface of the
asteroid so the next thing that we have
to worry about is
maintaining spacecraft safety there's a
lot of hazards
on this asteroid surface things that
could damage a critical component
and we decided to focus safety on the
things that were needed to get the
sample back to the earth
so there were certain things we could
lose at this point in the mission if
they didn't fulfill that objective
we still have some upcoming major
milestones that help us maintain that
spacecraft safety
now natural feature tracking is going to
be switching over to calculating
the contact point on the asteroid
surface and it has a piece of software
on board called the hazard map
it's actually determining is the
location that i'm going to touch down on
safe a green area on that hazard map or
is it potentially hazardous
a red area on that hazard map so as we
get closer to the asteroid surface
a key moment is the 5 meter crossing
that's when the spacecraft makes that
decision
do i continue down to collect the sample
or do i back away and live to tag
another day
after that you've got down there your
spacecraft is safe there's got to be
something for you to pick up
earlier in the broadcast beau beerhouse
showed us the size of particles that
tag sam could actually collect so we had
to map the nightingale area and other
potential sample sites
well below that two centimeter
resolution and in fact we got
3.5 millimeters per pixel
all over the nightingale sample site and
we were really excited to see
lots of particles uh of that size and of
course the final
uh parameter that we were looking at was
the scientific value
and i can tell you the good news is any
sample from bennu is scientifically
valuable we've seen these hydrated clay
minerals we've seen organic molecules
carbon bearing minerals all over the
surface of the asteroid
exactly the kind of material that we're
hoping to bring home
i understand the next big milestone
we're looking for here is something
called
match point that's right so what happens
at match point uh match point is the
final maneuver that the spacecraft uh
performs by firing its thrusters
and that's where we become
centered over the nightingale sample
site and begin that final descent down
to the asteroid surface
and the spacecraft is solely focused on
its safety
calculation and the decision on whether
or not it's going to proceed down to
collect that sample
of course the amazing thing about match
point is that the asteroid itself is
actually rotating
so when we go to match point the
spacecraft has to match the rotation of
the asteroid so it comes
directly down onto it that's right so
how fast has been rotating
venue has a rotation period of 4.3 hours
so that's basically the length of the
day
on on the asteroid on earth the rotation
period is 24 hours which is why a day on
earth is 24 hours long
so that translates because benny's a
pretty small object as we've seen 500
meters or about the same size as the
empire state building
at the equator the surface is moving at
10 centimeters per second
and it actually gets slower and slower
as you go to higher latitudes
by the time you get to the north pole
it's zero nightingale is pretty far
north so it's actually much lower than
10 centimeters per second
and that just kind of shows you the
delicate precision nature
of this mission you know we've got to
get very low thrust maneuvers
very delicate very slow approach to the
asteroid surface
everything kind of happens in slow
motion when you're operating in a
microgravity environment like venue
so what's the next critical milestone
after match point
uh after match point we're going to be
looking for the
natural feature tracking system coming
back online taking those images
and additional correlations and
precision on its
knowledge of its position and we might
expect it to actually jump up we've been
hearing
natural feature tracking uncertainties
on the order of half a meter
it may go up a little bit on ops
forex natural feature tracking system
has resumed processing
position uncertainty is 1.6 meters so
you can see there we went back to 1.6
meters that's because we went through
the checkpoint maneuver
so whenever you impart a thrust like
that it adds uncertainty into the system
uh and we're seeing that with the
natural feature tracking system right
now
that is so exciting okay so let's let's
we're gonna introduce actually the
associate administrator of nasa dr
thomas
booken thomas thank you for joining us
so glad to be here with all of you
it's an exciting time thomas happy
birthday thank you that's right
yesterday is his birthday yeah that's
right happy birthday so you know i guess
um
you know everybody here is aiming for
this point in time
called uh you know this tag sam but it
turns out that there have been a lot of
friends
a lot of colleagues that have helped get
us to this moment so you know
who who's been along with us on this
journey well look i mean
there's a number of of course domestic
partners many of them around here you
talk to some of them but there's also
international partners and the canadian
space agency provided the
laser altimeter which is an important
instrument here and of course we have a
partnership with jaxa uh what we what
we're going to do is actually share the
samples from
ryuko from hayabusa to with us sorry
threx once it's back for maximum science
and that's really what international
partnerships are about
so this is a big mission for nasa but it
turns out that there are many different
kinds of partners in a mission like this
can give us a sense of the range of
partners that we have
well look i mean it starts with the
university of arizona that's where the
leadership
is and with you there and your entire
team but nasa goddard space flight
center is a critical partner with
managing of course especially also
working with lockheed martin who really
you know with that team deserves a lot
of credit and kinetics which was already
introduced
as well as many others you know if you
really look so often
missions like that touch many many
states around the united states
absolutely so um thomas bookend thank
you for joining us and we will see you
later on in the program how do you feel
man
i'm pretty excited uh this is the final
like
10 12 minutes here for contact i feel
really good the team's in high spirits
as you and i talked about earlier this
week we have done everything possible to
make this today a success
exactly right and you know your your
mind is already out there and the
spacecraft is already on the way out in
real time can you imagine that right
it's good actually to point out whatever
has happened with tag has already
happened we're well past that 18 and a
half minute one-way lifetime
absolutely hey congrats let's continue
doing this yeah we'll see you later
thank you thomas
oh wow okay so we're coming up i know on
the uh the critical point of match point
so
um at what point will we know that we
know we really have a sample
that's a great question uh we we're not
exactly sure what's going to happen
right away
we'll know if we made contact with the
asteroid surface today
we'll know if the gas bottle fired and
we know that we backed safely away from
the asteroid
but we actually have a lot of work to do
over the next week or so
we'll take a look at the images that we
were acquired during contact with the
asteroid surface
and then we'll go into a different
imaging campaign uh
uh we're about 30 seconds from match
point so uh we're going to keep our ears
open for that critical call out from
dale
uh msa on rxops orex has processed its
next image
position uncertainty is one meter all
right we're back down to a meter
positional uncertainty that's great news
uh so back to sample verification um we
will
after we're well away from the asteroid
and everything has kind of settled down
we have that robotic arm we're actually
going to use that to put the tag sam
head into the field of view of
sam cam and we can look not only at the
top of the sampler head like we're going
to get with the images today but we can
actually turn it around
and we can look at the base of tag sam
we have in addition to the gas
stimulation we have
contact pads simply by making contact
with the asteroid surface we think we
can pick up fine grain particles
less than a millimeter or so but
basically we're going to be looking for
any evidence of asteroid material on or
inside the tag sam now obviously you
don't want to go all the way back
on orex ops match point burn is complete
all right we're heading down we've got
about 10 minutes
before contact with the asteroid surface
oh wow so i was about to say so
obviously you don't want to head back to
earth
with with not much samples how do you
know how much sample you actually got
uh there's an incredibly clever physics
experiment that the team has designed
here called the sample mass measurement
uh so what we're going to do is we're
going to place the spacecraft arm out to
the side of the spacecraft
so when it's in uh sampling
configuration it's actually pointed
above
for this we put it out in the other
direction and we kind of spin the entire
spacecraft around
and we're measuring a property called
the moment of inertia we have
actually already done this uh prior to
initiating the tag sequence today
so we know what that property is when
the tag sam head is empty
now we're going to be able to do it
hopefully when it's full of asteroid
regolith
so we're only looking for small
differences in this property
as a result of this experiment and the
precision just like everything on this
program
is phenomenal we're talking tens of
grams of precision on a measurement
on a spacecraft hundreds of millions of
miles away
that just picked up this asteroid sample
the minimum that we're looking for
is 60 grams or msa on rx ops
attitude control system has transitioned
to touch and go mode
right spacecraft's getting ready to make
contact with the asteroid surface here
so the sample mass measurement will tell
us if we have 60 grams or more of
material
and that will happen on saturday later
this week excellent
okay dante this is it you know the
engines have given us a push in the
right direction and osiris-rex is on
course to make touchdown on an asteroid
so we're going to listen to the flight
controller calls from msa but before we
actually touch the surface it's a great
time to visit our social media desk
again so
james what's going on yeah thanks
michelle so you've been hearing those
call-outs from dale over the
loudspeakers
about those nft images processing it'd
be awesome to actually grab a camera and
make the trek out to bennu to photograph
it up close in person
but you know as we've mentioned bennu is
a little bit far away from us right now
on the order of 200 million miles away
but don't worry here's something
osiris-rex can deliver to you
right now from the comfort of your own
home if you're on instagram you can head
over to at nasa solar system
we have two ar filters that you can use
on your social media stories
this first one is called osiris-rex and
u and features osiris-rex playing tag
with bennu around your head
the second one is called to bennu and
back it allows you to place an asteroid
wherever you are
at home at school bring an asteroid with
you
so i understand we have to have a
question coming in from instagram from
mauricio
who asks how do you manage the force
back from touching down
i mean the moment the spacecraft touches
the surface it should experience a
similar force in the opposite direction
how do you manage that well thanks
mauricio so the team actually thought
ahead for this one when designing that
sample arm
they actually added this spring-like
mechanism to it that you could think of
a bit like a pogo stick
if that sample arm were rigid when
contacting bennu
it would stop its downward motion and
when firing the gas bottle to stir up a
sample
we would just kick right back off into
space as beau bierhouse had mentioned
earlier
but since we have that spring you can
think of it like a pogo stick when you
make contact with the ground
the springs start compressing and you
keep your downward motion
it's sim same exact thing applies for
osiris-rex when we contact venue we
continue moving downward
and when we fire the gas bottles that
actually slows their downward motion
giving us just enough time at the
surface on the order of maybe 10 seconds
to stir up a sample before we kick right
back off into space
so if you actually want to see what the
tag event is going to look like up close
in person
we actually released a really cool 360
video on our nasa goddard youtube page
that parks you right on over xops
orex has processed its next image
position uncertainty
is 0.5 meters wow wow so this is really
really high detail right now we're
getting really close to the surface and
again like i was saying if you want to
experience what this is going to look
like up close
park yourself on the surface of
nightingale and look around this whole
terrain is actually generated using real
terrain data
down to two centimeter per pixel
resolution and as was mentioned earlier
by quarterly
that is actually higher resolution than
we've actually imaged our own earth and
moon so
really really beautiful imagery and
definitely encourage you to check that
out
but we're just minutes away from this
actually happening in real life so for
that
let's kick it back to you michelle okay
thanks james so
uh dante i i want to ask you a couple
personal questions here you've
spent about a third of your life working
on this mission
what are you feeling now uh it's a
pretty
amazing emotional state michelle when
you get to a point like this in
your career an event that you've worked
for for in my case over 16 years to get
here you kind of think back to all the
people
who have helped you i think about my
family i know they're watching
from tucson arizona right now they've
been really important to me
and another person who can't be with us
here tonight unfortunately is my mentor
dr michael drake
he's the one who invited me onto this
program in 2004
to be his deputy i was a young
bright-eyed assistant professor
and we worked together for seven years
writing proposals
to convince nasa that this was a program
to fly for new frontiers three
we won the contract for osiris-rex in
may of 2011
and mike passed away september a real
blow to the team so
i miss him i wish he was here today yeah
yeah it's very real i mean you know we
were connected to our avatars that we
put out there in the in the universe
yeah i know he'd be proud of us yeah and
he would really love it
uh to be with us right now so we're
looking at sort of an amazing uh
simulation right now so you know as we
mentioned before uh these are not actual
images from spacecraft but these are
based on a huge amount of real data
so we're actually looking down as this
uh tag exam instrument starts
approaching its uh its
sample site yeah we are collecting tons
of images right now but we simply don't
have the data rate to get them back to
the earth in real time so they're just
getting banked into the spacecraft's
memory
and we're going to start looking at
those later tonight and have them
available for everybody tomorrow morning
so this is just a simulation of the
field of view of the sam cam the
sampling camera
part of our ocam's camera suite uh it
has a clear shot of the tag sam
collector right in the middle of its
field of view you can actually see the
lower end of the tag sam arm here
overx msa on orexos orex is descending
below 25 meters
okay we're getting really close uh i
want to remind you it's the five meter
crossing
that's the really critical one we're
only a couple minutes away from that
so the spacecraft has one key decision
left to make
it's calculating right now the
probability that it's going to come down
either on a hazardous area as we defined
on that hazard map or in a safe area
so we may at five meters the spacecraft
may decide that it's hazardous and it's
gonna back away
allowing us to live the tag another day
so to me
uh all my senses are on that call out
right now i really wanna hear
that we are go for tag so that's just a
couple minutes away here
and of course remember that that was
planned for that yeah it has to know
it's safe otherwise it's going to back
up and try again another time that's
really how we solve the amazing
challenges that this asteroid surface
presented to us you can see here that
this is a pretty daunting terrain
that we're coming down here uh there's
giant boulders all around the
nightingale site
even some large rocks inside the crater
that we do not
think the spacecraft would survive at
least uh with the ability to return back
to earth if it made contact
so it is there to protect itself first
and foremost
safety is always first uh but we're
feeling pretty good everything's gone
really well today so i would say
things are looking great for for a tag
but of course the spacecraft is the one
that gets to make that decision
it's just amazing we've been rehearsing
this event you know all week long all
the different
mission calls and milestones but then to
actually be here tonight
and realize that this is going on 200
million miles away that's right
yeah i'm pretty excited
so i mean there were obviously a lot of
firsts in this mission msa on rxops
orex has processed its next message
position uncertainty is 0.5 meters
predicted tag
lateral offset is 1.7 meters
hazard probability is 0
ag lateral velocity is 0.2
millimeters per second vertical velocity
is 10.2 centimeters per second
that sounded really good yes so it
sounds like the hazard map calculation
looks really good
at that we're coming down in a green
area we're going to make contact with
the asteroid surface
ah well remember how historic this this
is nasa's first mission to retrieve a
sample from an asteroid
a pristine part of the solar system just
look at that animation now
so we're looking at looking at the team
i think i think we can see
everybody is laser focused on what the
spacecraft's going to do so i say let's
let this play out
but those calls were really great that
was great news from dale yeah
even more accurate than we hoped for in
some cases
everybody seems happy
so i guess you know there were obviously
a lot of firsts in this mission and
there was a time when you said you know
a lot of what-ifs basically you know i
mean what if we could actually send a
spacecraft
to an asteroid what if we really could
bring back a sample of the solar system
from billions of years ago
did you remember where you were when
those those what if there was msa on
orex ops
orex has descended below the five meter
mark
the hazard map is go for tag expected in
50 seconds
we're going in
sampling is in progress
oh my gosh um we're there folks that was
amazing
i mean i don't know if you saw the team
here but they just kind of blew up they
went from being steely eyed to like
celebrating the super bowl so um so it's
all good
this is amazing so congratulations
everybody i know that dante and dr
brookin are right here and dante you
somehow got over here pretty quick
congratulations how you guys feeling uh
transcendental i mean i can't believe we
actually pulled this off
god i'm so excited about the team do you
mind if i just bring up something
please out front mike drake is with us
right now that's right now you came up
with the mission at the beginning and uh
we're thinking of him he's no longer on
earth i feel him right here i agree he's
with us today
and i know he's incredibly proud of this
team and everything we have accomplished
this is history
uh it's amazing i can barely speak you
know i'm like shaking how about you
yeah absolutely uh it's almost hard to
process
everything that's happening right now
it's it's overwhelming pride
in this team and everything we've done
to get here uh i couldn't
really have anything better to say about
this group of people
oh rex msa on norwex op sample
collection is complete
and the back away burn has executed
all right
[Music]
now dante that was actually a really
important call we were celebrating on
the tag
that was actually probably even more
important called why is that
the pyro bottles fired so tag sam
operated
the back away thruster is fired so we're
safely moving away from the asteroid
surface
the spacecraft did everything it was
supposed to do uh so
we did it we tagged the surface of the
asteroid and it's up to bennu now to see
how the event went
what does this mean to nasa oh i mean
this is g
key meltdown of this now it's a few days
right to figure out how much we caught
off this
amazing example that's right for decades
but uh i think this is just i'm so proud
of this team
oh my goodness oh my goodness
well i gotta tell you this this has been
a fantastic day a fantastic journey
we're so proud of both of you for being
here and supporting that team
we're going to get back over to the
stage and michelle but
some really good news so back to you
michelle thank you
[Music]
this is one of those moments we're all
aware of kobit 19 because i want the
hugs and high fives and everything but
we're all going to keep each other safe
there are lots of super excited people
all over who want to share in this
moment
and share their congratulations so let's
take a moment to hear a few words from
three institutional leaders who couldn't
be here tonight
but they're cheering on the team on
behalf of so many supporters
hi everyone dennis andrews at goddard
center director
i am just so excited that osiris-rex
is coll is collecting a sample from the
surface of the new
the tag is just the pinnacle of the
mission so
correct msa go back to earth over
obviously going to be that's completed a
great event
microwave entire mission but i gotta
congratulate
you and your team your project
management skills as a pi
just just superb rich the operations
team for getting us to where we are
and lisa at lisa callahan for the
awesome lockheed martin team
uh and getting osiris-rex to where we
are
and building a great spacecraft and
returning it to earth
go osiris-rex
today is an exciting day as osiris-rex
begins its descent to bennu
the nation is looking forward to the
news of a successful tag event
osiris-rex team members have been
working on this project for more than a
decade
and the work being done is hard and it's
complicated and it's necessary
understanding the makeup of bennu will
help us better understand our universe
and how to protect our most important
asset in space
earth i want to wish the best of luck to
the entire osiris-rex team
including our partners at the nasa
goddard space flight center
the university of arizona and especially
the mission operators and engineers
right here
at lockheed martin go rex
the university of arizona is incredibly
proud of its long tradition of
excellence and leadership in space
exploration
i'm thrilled to see the osiris-rex's
missions achievements carried
this tradition forward today with nasa
lockheed martin and all of our
incredible partners
congratulations to all of the osiris-rex
mission team members
you have shown the world how our
determination creativity and talent can
advance
the capabilities of our entire nation
and i can't wait for the amazing science
we will see
with the sample return in 2023
okay well we are here live after some
excellent news i'm here with an exultant
dante loretta from the university of
arizona so one more time for our
audience out there
explain when we know we'll have a sample
a little overwhelmed right now michelle
i have to say it's been pretty intense
several minutes here i can tell you that
everything went
just exactly perfect which is kind of
the hallmark of this team
we have consistently beaten expectations
over and over again
we have overcome the amazing challenges
that this asteroid has thrown at us
and the spacecraft appears to have
operated flawlessly
uh we made it down to the asteroid
surface we were in contact
the gas bottles fired uh we don't know
how long we were in contact
with yet that's uh some reconstructed uh
information that we're gonna have to put
together over the next few hours as the
data come in
uh we backed away successfully from the
asteroid surface
the team is exuberant back there uh
emotions are high
everybody is really proud and uh
we have some work to do uh to determine
how much sample that we have collected
uh the next thing that i'm gonna be
looking for is uh once the spacecraft
cools off it probably got pretty warm as
it approached the asteroid surface so it
needs to get rid of some of that excess
heat it's got to get those solar rays
back onto the sun
and get power positive once it's
stabilized it's going to point that high
gain antenna at the earth and we're
going to start bringing that data back
and those sam cam
images are going to tell us an enormous
amount of information about how the
events of today went
we're going to be looking at a whole
series of images as we descended down to
the surface
made contact fired that gas bottle and i
really want to know how that surface
responded
we haven't done this before so this is a
new territory for us
and the whole science team i know is
really looking forward to that
information
uh for one thing it'll tell us the
likelihood of
sample collection kind of a
probabilistic assessment
probably a lot of uh science that comes
out of that as well yeah well listen
i know you want to be back there with
your team it's going to be a long
hopefully happy night for all of you as
more data comes in thank you so much
it's been such an honor to be with you
thank you thank you everybody for for a
great evening
and uh kudos to this team it's it's an
amazing experience
and history was made tonight absolutely
so you know what we're going to do now
is actually take a closer look at this
beautiful terrain that we've actually
sampled
we've identified over a million
asteroids in the solar system
but remember bennu is what's called a
neo a near-earth asteroid
so instead of orbiting in the main
asteroid belt between mars and jupiter
it has an orbit very similar to our own
planet earth and it not only gets our
attention
because it's so close to earth but also
because we believe it may be one of the
older bodies in the solar system with a
wealth of information
about how the solar system and life
began let's take a closer look at the
subject of
all of this activity all of this joy
tonight thank you let's take a tour
in december 2018 after traveling for two
years
101 days in over 1.2 billion miles
nasa's osiris-rex spacecraft arrived at
its target
near-earth asteroid bennu osiris-rex
is the first mission to explore this
primitive remnant from the origins of
the solar system
designed to study the asteroid and
return a sample to earth
bennu is a dark diminutive world roughly
the height of a skyscraper
and now the smallest body to be orbited
by a spacecraft
prior to arrival it was known to have
low thermal inertia
a characteristic of fine-grained
materials like sand
an infrared spectrometer on osiris-rex
confirmed this property
leading scientists to expect a
predominantly smooth surface
but the first close-up views of bennu
delivered a major surprise
in exquisite detail the mission's
cameras revealed an unrelenting
rockscape
dominated by boulders by combining these
images from osiris-rex
with its laser altimetry data we can
take a tour of bennu's remarkable
terrain
the first stop is simmering saxon this
prominent boulder
defines the asteroids prime meridian and
serves
as the basis of its coordinate system in
persian mythology
the simrac is a large and benevolent
bird and the possessor of all knowledge
saxon is latin for stone to the
northeast
lies the largest boulder on bennu
measuring over 300 feet in length
rock saxon is a colossus longer than a
football field
it is also rich in a type of iron oxide
called
magnetite which was used by mariners as
an early form
of magnetic compass in arab folklore
the rock is an enormous bird of prey
that can clasp elephants in its talons
as well as stranded sailors like the
hero sinbad
continuing northeast over the equatorial
ridge we arrive
at gargoyle saxon this striking boulder
is among the darkest on bennu though it
clutches a much brighter rock that is
about the size of a person
in medieval legend gargoyles are
dragon-like
winged monsters that can breathe fire
and that guard cathedrals from evil
spirits
our next destination takes us far to the
east
at the northern end of a small crater
lies acipidy saxon
a comparatively bright boulder measuring
about 33 feet
in diameter oscipide saxon is located
near one of three sites
where bennu ejected small particles into
space in early 2019
displaying its dynamic and evolving
nature
in greek mythology osipity is one of the
three harpies
the half-maiden half-bird
personifications of stormwinds
who would carry evildoers away from the
earth
in the creation stories of ancient egypt
the universe
began as a formless endless expanse of
water
from this primordial sea arose the
primordial mound
ben ben it was upon this rock that the
god of adam settled in the form of the
bennu bird
and sent forth the call that shaped
creation
the story of ben ben harkens to the
mounds of fertile silt that once emerged
from the receiving flood waters of the
nile
and it provides a fitting namesake for
the tallest boulder on bennu
protruding by over 70 feet benben saxon
is so tall that it was first detected
from earth
now we can appreciate this monumental
feature in detail
using data from osiris-rex
the final stop on our tour is a cluster
of exceptionally bright
boulders scattered across the southern
hemisphere
they bear the spectral fingerprint of
pyroxene a mineral found in igneous rock
that is unlikely to have formed on bennu
these boulders most likely originated on
the large asteroid
vesta and were delivered to bennu's
parent body through meteoroid impacts
although it is small in size asteroid
bennu has proved to be a fascinating
world
abundant in geographic features that
have defied our expectations
thanks to osiris-rex we can now explore
bennu
to uncover its composition its evolution
and its ancient memories from the
origins of the solar system
[Music]
if everything has gone right tonight a
little bit of bennu will be coming back
to earth in 2023
so let's get one last visit with our
social media desk james what's going on
yeah michelle i've got goosebumps i
really can't even begin to fathom that
we just
tagged and collected a sample from this
asteroid 200 million miles away
i know i'm going to want to relive the
events that just unfolded tonight i'm
sure you will as well so once again
if you have that 360 video up on our
nasa goddard youtube page
go check it out put yourself right where
the action just happened a couple
minutes ago
it's truly mind-blowing stuff i also
want to check back in with that twitter
poll that we put out at the beginning of
the broadcast
and we're asking you how much material
you think we just got from asteroid
bennett
so remember we're looking for at least
60 grams but that sample container can
hold up to
two kilograms so you guys are saying
that a candy bar
size of sample i like the optimism let's
hope we actually pack that container to
the max and bring
all the sample back home but any sample
we get back is truly magical and will
help us
learn more about the solar system and
our origins here so
keep at us on the hashtag to benue and
back we're excited to keep this
conversation going as we look to bring
that sample
all the way back from bennu here to
earth in 2023.
so back to you michelle
this is one of these evenings where it's
such a privilege and a pleasure to be
working for nasa and for the idea of
scientific exploration
so what we've been doing all evening is
seeing the joy seeing these people that
have worked on this for decades
but you have to remember there's a real
reason we're going to look at these
asteroids
we think we actually might be coming
back with a baby picture
of what the solar system was like of
what our chemistry was like
billions of years ago we're looking for
our own origins out there and that's why
we've gone
so far to bring a bit of bennu back this
has been an incredible evening
the adrenaline is slowly beginning to
slowly go down and
there's going to be a lot of celebration
and a lot of work in the coming hours
so from lockheed martin space here in
lilton colorado
i'm dr michelle thaller good night
however whenever
we're here there
[Music]
we're everywhere
[Music]
nasa space communications and navigation
exploration enabled
well in my left hand i have a feather
in my right hand a hammer i guess one of
the reasons
uh we got here today was because of a
gentleman named galileo a long time ago
who made a rather significant discovery
about falling objects in gravity fields
and we thought that where would be a
better place
to confirm his findings and on the move
and so we thought we'd try it here for
you the feather happens to be
appropriately about
[Music]
you